dissimulés au coeur des plus grands
chefs-d'oeuvre et vestiges de notre
histoire d'or un secret aussi ancien que
la civilisation un chien bien
particulier et un jeune garçon qui
apparaissent régulièrement au cours des
âges qui sont ils que veulent t'ils d'où
vient-il
les réponses pourraient être enfin
révélé dans le plus grand mystère de
l'histoire un chien et son fils ces
symboles furent découverts dans la tombe
du pharaon toutankhamon
celui-là sherman ses droits tout veux tu
que je les fasse écorché vif en dur de
miel et qu'on les jette dans une hausse
plein de fourmis rouges quoi bonté
divine sans appel
il n'explique ablement ils
réapparaissent en 200 ans avant
jésus-christ au commencement de la
guerre de troie est allé sur le champ de
bataille ammann s affirme a dit ce
monsieur ahmed sheikh van geyte interdit
formellement de perdre la guerre de
troie
c'est dangereux
et plus tard à la renaissance ces deux
figures mystérieuse pourrait être à
l'origine d'un certain sourire je ne
peux pas de moi une chose qui pourrait
me faire nourrit peut-être puis-je vous
être de quelque utilité
serait-il possible qu'ils aient tous les
deux voyager à travers le temps c'est
une machine à remonter le temps je l'ait
appelé le chronomat bas aujourd'hui mais
c'est peabody
waouh sherman
préparez vous à vivre une aventure je ne
loupe jamais flash info
d'une portée historique à drogue toi
bien sûr que non dreamworks présentent
monsieur peabody et sherman les voyages
dans le temps